in this episode we're going to replicate
Facebook reactions using angular for and
firebase first let's head over to
Facebook just to see how it works you
can hover over like button which brings
up a tooltip with all the different
reactions when you click reaction it
updates your own as well as the list of
other users reactions below that first
thing we're going to do is import the
graphics into our project I found some
free Facebook icons on icon finder calm
and then save them under the assets
folder in the angular project now we can
generate the reaction service and import
the angularfire
auth module as well as the database
module we're also going to make heavy
use of lodash to handle the sorting and
counting of reactions we'll keep track
of the user ID on the service and then
we create an array of the actual emoji
graphics we want each emoji to be tied
to a specific index and we'll save that
index in the database in this case light
will be 0 loved one Wow 2 etc so our
database is a collection of item IDs
things that can be reacted to and each
document is the keys of the users and
the number that corresponds to their
reaction the first thing we'll do is get
the associated reaction score and item
as a firebase object observable next we
create a function that allows the user
to update their reaction which has a
default value of 0 for life we format
the data by passing the user ID is the
key and the reaction is the value and
then we just update that object in
firebase following the same idea we
create another function that allows the
user to remove their reaction from the
database now we create a utility
function to counsel reactions to come
back from firebase it returns a
JavaScript object where the key is the
value of the reaction and the value is
the number of reactions for that type
we'll use it to display the total count
for each reaction type in the component
template the final step is to determine
the current users reaction so we just
check the object for that specific user
ID now we can start building the
front-end component first we're going to
need the input decorator as well as
ondestroy and we'll also inject the
reaction service and we'll use lo - in
here as well the component will accept
an input variable which represents the
parents ID that can be any kind of
content that can be reacted to then
we'll declare a few other variables that
represent the data we're going to be
showing in the template during ng on a
knit we first get big lists of emoji
then we subscribe to the object
observable when it emits a value it'll
be a JavaScript object of user IDs and
their reactions we can use this object
to count the total reactions for each
type as well as determine the current
users reaction from there we create an
event handler that will actually update
or remove a reaction if the user already
has a reaction with a matching value
then we'll go ahead and delete that
reaction if the value is different
it means the users updating or creating
a new reaction so we go ahead and update
that in the database next we create
another event handler that will require
when the user hovers over the like
button which will show the emojis and we
create a utility method to return the
emoji image path in the assets folder
and one more utility method to see if a
reaction type has reactions so we know
whether or not to display it in the
template then we unsubscribe when the
components destroyed to avoid memory
leaks now let's put this all together in
the component HTML first we create a
wrapper around everything and use the
mouse enter mouse we've events to toggle
the physical
of the emojis inside this div we loop
over the six emojis and use our emoji
pass helper to find the Associated
graphic in the assets folder notice how
we also get the index while looping
through this array because that will be
the value we save to the database
corresponding to this reaction type next
we'll add a like button that the user
can click that will add just a generic
light if the user has liked this piece
of content we'll go ahead and add a
conditional class that will color a blue
and make it bold and also we want to
display the type of reaction the users
have in both cases we check to see if
the user reaction is not null we can use
the value of the reaction to get the
corresponding emoji from the emoji list
and it's indexed now we need to display
the total reaction Cal we do this by
looping over the emoji list again and
we'll see if a reaction has taken place
and then we'll get the total count for
that reaction just like before we use
the Emoji path helper to display the
corresponding image then we can get the
count from our reaction count object by
just passing up that index let's try it
out in the app if we hover over the like
button it should bring up the emojis and
if we click it it should add a light
telling us what the light type is the
reaction counts are all kept up to date
in real time so if we have multiple
users reacting to the same piece of
content we'll see the reaction counts be
updated in real time when looking into
the database console we can see that
going to user clicks the reaction it
adds their user ID key and the value for
that reaction to the database
that's it for this episode if you found
the video helpful please like and
subscribe and if you want to support the
channel consider becoming a pro
subscriber at angular firebase comm for
just a few bucks a month you'll get
access to your exclusive content as well
as free one on one project consulting
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]